when i met you a couple of years ago you
know
you were a party boy and now
you're a serious machine am i correct
you did something you started running
you started eating right
cut back on the alcohol yeah pretty much
all of that uh i think becoming a dad um
just shifted my bedtime which then
shifted my uh waking up time which then
once you're up you're up and uh
yeah so i would get up with my daughter
at like five give her breakfast and then
take her in the gym and do a workout
with her i was going to say about bad
habits i think it's a love song a
farewell love song to your bad habits uh
you know yeah i probably open a bottle
of wine at like 7 p.m at night right and
then whatever happens after that happens
and
you know
and then i got to the realization of
like what if cherry's water breaks
tonight at 8 pm and i can't drive her to
the hospital and i have to ring someone
and then they drive i mean i would feel
like the worst husband so about like
three months before
three months before lyra was born i was
like right this is my last day of
having it the reason the album is called
equals
is
the equals is in between a question and
an answer right it's the end of an
answer end of a question and start of an
answer and i really feel like your 30s
are when questions start to be answered
you're in your 20s like i remember
turning 21 and being like i'm a grown-up
now but still doing all the like 18 year
old [ __ ] that you know i would still
my my my meal plan would be fries it
would be like right where where are we
getting that that would just be it you
know like um and then throughout your
20s you're sort of you're sort of dating
and you're finding out
what sort of uh what sort of food you
like what sort of drink you like whether
you like clubs because that's another
thing when you're 18 uh no when you're
17 you look at clubs as this thing that
are going to be the most like oh my god
i can't wait to go clubbing i remember
the first time walking into a club being
like
this is [ __ ] like you have to queue up
20 minutes to buy a 10 pound
pint and then you can't even speak to
your friends and then like yeah mate i
just i just remember it being so anyway
you spend your 20s figuring that [ __ ]
out now you're all cleaned up you're
muscular i mean you're like a different
man when you take your clothes off for
your wife and and it's time to get busy
does she look at you now go holy [ __ ]
this is like a whole new man
um there is a fine balance there because
you never want to be the most in shape
one out of the two and she is very in
shape because she plays she plays hockey
but i think she preferred i think
honestly she preferred me with a bit of
meat on the bench
but the thing is i think she likes i
think she likes that i'm i'm healthy
like i'm not a sluggish individual
anymore like i am up early i'm you know
my day is full of stuff i'm not like
on tour i would i would wake up at like
2 p.m
underneath a venue
and then sort of like hang out and then
go on stage once the sun had gone down
and then play the gig and then go out
and then fall asleep on the bus and go
to the next place and i just you just
don't see sunlight